okay
hi there um welcome to another episode
of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
it is a busy day for me today so uh i'm
a little bit um um uh
having to shift gears here let's
see um looking at
questions here uh
there's questions here about um
uh well
the question here about um uh sleep
um and uh
uh so so you know it's a really strange
thing because one would
think that uh sleep being such a
widespread kind of phenomenon
that it will be completely understood
why
one sleeps what the function of sleep is
or maybe it's just a biological mistake
so to speak
you know people often say anything that
happens in biology has to happen for a
reason
that that organisms can evolve
absolutely anything that organisms could
evolve uh um you know 17
eyes and could evolve this and could
evolve that if it was good
for them to do that it's kind of the the
theory of
the anything is possible theory of
evolution it's not clear that that's
correct
because whatever an organism is supposed
to have
somehow has to grow as part of the
organism's development
so if you know if you were going to have
wheels there has to be a way to actually
grow a wheel
um and uh if there isn't then even if
it might be a really good thing to have
wheels um you're not going to be able to
have organisms that have those
but any case sleep is one of those
things where people have sort of debated
what is the function of sleep
um endlessly and uh there are a whole
variety of theories and i think
it's it's still quite up in the air what
the what the correct story is
i mean one of the more perhaps amusing
theories is
the function of sleep is to keep animals
out of the way at night so they don't uh
uh cause trouble for themselves um i
think that's
that's to me what seems rather one of
the more implausible theories
um but you know if you look at what
organisms sleep
um i think going down to certainly fish
and things like that there is a very
definite
uh different state that um organisms get
into when they're
sort of not um not in their standard
sort of
conscious awake state i mean some
organisms i think
uh cartilaginous fish sharks and so on
have all kinds of elaborate things where
they can you know one half of their
brain can go to sleep and the other one
doesn't
all sorts of weird things like that um
but generally this idea of multiple
states of the brain
ones that are awake and sort of paying
attention and ones that are asleep
and somehow doing something
that provides rest for the organism
that seems to exist across a wide
spectrum of different kinds of organisms
and we certainly know for for us
when we sleep if you look at the the
brain waves that we generate
the electrical activity in our brains
all our various hundred billion neurons
are all little things that have
electrical impulses
that they're generating a thousand times
a second or whatever
that uh make our brains operate the way
they operate but if you look at that
on a sort of large scale you just say
what's the what's the average amount of
electrical activity in the brain
you can see these kind of waves that go
uh the there's a there's a prominent one
the alpha rhythm at around nine
uh nine cycles per second um
but there's another one i think it's the
theta rhythm which starts up when one
goes to sleep
and that seems to be a a kind of a a a
feature a large-scale feature of the
brain
that's characteristic of sleep so okay
so what does sleep do for one well
there are there are theories like um
sleep uh
well okay another thing to say is that
there are
um different phases of sleep you know
even typical
um uh fitness trackers
will often give you some trace of the
different stages of sleep
and they do that by by by noticing
uh two basic things noticing your heart
rate and noticing whether you're
wiggling around or not
um because in different phases of sleep
the um uh
the the sort of you're completely still
or you
um or you're kind of or your muscles are
kind of wiggling around
um they're i think uh well the the um
there's uh
several stages of sleep there's kind of
light sleep deep
sleep and rem sleep um rem sleep is kind
of the most
perhaps the most bizarre um it's one
where rem stands for rapid eye motion
and uh your eyes kind of move around all
over the place
um i guess that's the phase of sleep in
which dreams occur
and whether you remember your dreams is
probably
somewhat related to whether you happen
to wake up soon after you've been in a
rem sleep period or not
i think i think rem sleep if i remember
correctly is is the period in which
uh you kind of in which all motion is
kind of cut off
so your while your brain may be thinking
about moving around
um it's uh your actual muscles are not
um that's probably an evolutionarily
good thing because otherwise you'd be
flopping around
and um uh and um if you were
an organism that slept in a tree or
something that might be a very bad thing
for you
um but um i think the um uh the question
the function uh you know what's
happening in
in um uh the sort of a question of why
uh why does rem sleep occur why do
dreams occur
um uh the the um there are
the different kinds of ideas about that
i mean i think one thing that is pretty
clear
is that dreams are sort of related to an
internally generated stimulus and then
your brain trying to make sense of that
internally generated stimulus
i mean we know that our brains are
constantly trying to sort of fill things
in
that seem plausible given some
particular stimulus that we had
i mean a very famous example of that is
if you
um it's a visual uh kind of
hack um so if you have your eye
your eye has your retina at the back of
your eye which is the part that senses
light
it's kind of like the um the array of uh
the the sort of
pixel array inside a standard digital
camera these days
the array of there's an array of cells
on the back of your retinas and a little
hexagonal
grid basically and they're about um uh
there are let's see i think they're
about a million pixels there but they
sort of uh multiply up to about 10
million pixels
when they do a little bit of local image
processing um to do that
um and um that but anyway so
what what happens is the light falls on
your retina it
um uh these these um when when light
falls that
just like in a digital camera the um uh
where the light falls a little
electrical
impulses generated there's a cell that
is a photoreceptor
that has the feature that when a photon
of light hits it um
it produces an electrical pulse those
electrical pulses are collected up
and are fed to one's optic nerve that
goes from the retina
the eye to the visual cortex which is
rather badly designed
by being at the back of one's head so
that the optic nerve has to go all the
way through
through the brain to get to the back of
the back
um where the first levels of processing
of the visual scene happen
but any case the um so one of the
features is uh
where that you have your retina and
again it's maybe not
such spectacular design the um the optic
nerve
um actually attaches to the eye on a
part of the retina
and so what you what you see is there's
retina and then there's a place
on the retina where there aren't any
photoreceptors because that's kind of
where the optic nerve
is getting all its connections from the
the photoreceptors
on the retina and taking them taking
them uh
out through your brain so that means
that on your retina there's a hole
where there are no photoreceptors you
can't see anything
on that part of your your um uh your
eye and so the for humans the optic
nerve is on the
sort of on the inside so both eyes are
sort of this blind spot
um that is you know on the nose side of
the eye so to speak
okay so the trick you can do is you
cover one eye you get a piece of graph
paper
and you you can write a big spot on the
graph paper
and if you move your eye to the right
distance and you keep focused straight
ahead
then that big spot that you drew on the
graph paper will end up being
exactly where your optic nerve is will
it will correspond to that that
that image will fall on the part of your
retina that corresponds to where your
optic nerve is going
and where you have no photoreceptors so
you cannot see that that big blob that
you put down on the graph paper
so what does your brain do about that
well what your brain does is it just
fills in graph paper there
it's it doesn't uh you know you ignore
the fact that there's
you can't see the blob but then the
question is do you just leave a blank
a this is missing missing data as a
computer might
might want to tell you well missing data
is filled in as something by your brain
and it's filled in your brain tends to
say well what are the sort of patterns
of what's going on here
let me fill it in according to extending
the pattern of what's going on there
and so you get the sort of extension of
the graph paper even though if you move
your eye you can see there's a scraping
blob there
so this is a very typical thing that our
brains do it's something that we now
know that artificial neural nets are
also very good at doing
is kind of taking what we know happens
in the world and kind of
extrapolating kind of deducing what the
consequences you know fill in the pieces
that
that you couldn't actually see but were
sort of the natural thing that your
brain sort of has seen examples of
before
that kind of are what might happen and i
think the
the general the general assumption is
that dreams are kind of
that story that there's some sort of
internal stimulus
and then you're like well if if this
happened then your brain fills in well
this and this and this and this must
happen
and so you know when there are sort of
psychological interpretations of dreams
i think a lot of that story is about
well those are the things that your
brain is used to saying have to happen
and so when that sort of this random
stimulus comes in
and then your brain says well that means
i must be
uh you know in this situation that
situation whatever
um those are the things that are sort of
that that have been imprinted on your in
your in your mind
um as sort of what typically happens if
this happens so
so they do provide some uh some sort of
uh
insight into the way that you're
thinking about things even if that's not
the way that you would sort of
consciously surface
what you would say that the things that
your brain has kind of decided
are the natural thing that happens you
know when you run into this person the
natural thing that happens is
that the person uh you know says
something terrible
whatever that that's um that's what your
brain has sort of decided
is um is going on even if you couldn't
necessarily verbalize and consciously
say that and i think that's kind of
what what people assume is happening in
the case of dreams
but you know there's a question of
what's actually going on in the brain
um when um when one's sleeping what
what's some
i think the the most plausible theory
i suspect is that there's just gunk that
builds up in our brains when we when we
operate our brain during the day
um we uh uh we just um uh you know we
the the brain is active there's some
there's little
you know electrical pulses each
electrical pulse is associated with a
chemical process
the chemical process has a certain
amount of waste product
um probably and uh sleep is probably the
time when
it's okay shut everything down stop
doing all that thinking stuff
and just clean out the the waste
products that got generated by by the
activity during
during the day um i think i don't know
seen a particular
chemical is one that's been implicated
as being the thing that
you have to clean out and i i guess it's
it's sort of uh
the process of cleaning it out as i say
you have to kind of shut things down
to kind of wipe it all clean and be
ready for the next day
uh now you know it it's some in a sense
i think one has the it's a little bit
like what happens when one
you know moves one's muscles you know
when one moves one's muscles what's
happening is there's a
the nerves are sending an electrical
signal to the muscles muscles are made
of these uh
proteins actin which is this long
filamentous protein
and when when it's uh subjected to this
uh electrical pulse from
from a nerve it will can uh it will be
can it will contract
um but that whole process of giving the
energy to do that
is is part of a whole um sort of cycle
of energy production
which has a um uh which has a kind of
waste product
which is lactic acid and so when you
kind of move your muscles around
um uh actually i'm i'm not completely
certain whether that's
um uh to what extent that is the
electrochemistry of the nerve
versus the um uh versus the pure muscle
activity
that leaves over lactic acid but any
case the
the um you uh uh you do this
and uh you generate lactic acid and
that's the kind of the thing when your
muscles kind of
you know feeling tired that's some uh
that's a thing that has built up there
and you have to kind of um
wait to clear that out for your muscles
to be not tired anymore and one assumes
that something pretty similar is
happening in the brain
certainly that's one's perception when
one feels tired
i i think it's sort of one's perception
is a little bit like muscles feeling
tired
and certainly the same word is used to
describe those two at least in english
so so you know a a plausible theory is
that just waste products built up in the
brain and that's some
what you have to clear out now there are
some more exotic theories
that say things like oh uh you know
when when the brain is sleeping it's
reorganizing the memories that has been
formed during the day
might be true i think we don't have as
much evidence for that as we might think
given that we now understand artificial
neural networks which really don't
seem to need a phase like that you might
think oh our memories are stored in
these very complicated ways in our brain
you know let's try and organize our
memories um
it doesn't seem to be artificial neural
nets don't do that
um and they haven't seem to have a need
for that now one thing that probably is
true
is that rehearsing our memories like
there are things
you know that i learned 50 years ago or
something that
um if i haven't thought about them in 50
years
um maybe there's much less chance that i
will remember them
than if i kind of have rehearsed them
multiple times in that
in that intervening period i mean it's
it's part of the um
uh i mean this whole question about how
you best remember
things people have studied this quite a
bit it's kind of like
um uh you know if you're trying to um uh
learn things for a test or something you
know what's the optimal way to do it
what's the optimal kind of repetition
period do you have
what what people look at in sort of the
psychology world is this idea of
learning curves
if you're if you're learning something
um what
um uh you know but by what uh you know
as you as you repeat
sort of trying things out how
how rapidly do you become successful at
doing that particular task you know if
you're trying to
i don't know um do some kind of
thing in a video game or you're trying
to do some manual task where you're you
know
i don't know tying some weird knot or
you're throwing something in some
particular way
how many trials does it take before you
reach what level of proficiency
in doing that particular task that's the
kind of story of the learning curve
and typically what happens is there's a
sort of uh typically it's a kind of a
rapid beginning where you learn
you know you get quite a lot you get
faster you get better at doing that task
quite quite quickly and then it kind of
slows down and eventually reach some
kind of saturation where you're at the
maximum stage
and it's kind of when you practice
something you know you practice the
piano you practice something else
this is all sort of trying to push up
this learning curve
to get to the point where you have sort
of rehearsed things enough
that um uh that you can be successful at
doing them you've sort of trained
yourself to be able to do them and i
think
this this notion of training which
certainly humans have understood well
for a long time whether you're
you know training yourself to do some
particular kind of thing so you can
you can do it well and you can do it
even without thinking too much about
it you can just sort of naturally do it
just because you've trained yourself to
do it is really the same story in in the
artificial neural networks that we use
today
except they don't really have the
thinking phase they just have to be
trained
to uh uh to do the thing so uh let's see
what else to say about sleep i think
that the you know another thing is
it's very common in biology once you
have some big
uh phenomenon that's happening biology
says okay great there's this phenomenon
happening
let's pile on a lot of other things that
can be put into that
other sort of uh that can be put along
with that phenomenon so
once we know we sleep so to speak then
let's go and let's have all kinds of uh
uh sort of endocrine uh functions that
correlate with that let's have these
other kinds of things that correlate
with that and so on so
so the things that there end up being
all these things that happen when one is
asleep
which one doesn't really know what's
cause and what's effect
was it that sleep is needed because of
clearing out stuff from the brain or
something
and then by the way given that you're
just lying still for for however many
hours
um then then um we might as well
also do these things while while you're
asleep and an evolution
sort of led one to say let's put these
functions
um in the time when when one is asleep
uh you know there are also questions
about sort of how often does one sleep
and how much does one need to sleep and
so on
there's this whole notion of the
circadian rhythm the fact that
you know we we roughly we live on a
planet that has a roughly a 24-hour day
and uh so we roughly end up
synchronizing our sleep wakefulness
to that 24-hour period um and uh
uh the sort of the way that that seems
to happen
is largely uh through that's very simple
process of we see light
light comes into our eyes uh it's sort
of uh a
decently intense light ends up being the
thing that sort of drives
kind of the the synchronization of our
circadian rhythm
and ultimately it's it's something where
um
the uh pituitary gland i guess in the
brain is involved
in secreting um various chemicals
melatonin and things like this
that uh are associated with uh the
the process of of sleep and wakefulness
but but pretty soon if you've been sort
of driven
by oh the sun is coming up and going
down and and everything's on this
24-hour cycle
your body will adapt to yes it's going
to follow this 24-hour cycle
um so uh when for example if
for every particular person i don't know
whether it varies with time of life or
not
but if you if you were actually sort of
uh putting yourself in this completely
darkened room you don't know anything
about what time it is you have no clocks
computers clock is switched off all that
kind of thing
your circadian rhythm will drift and
most people have a circadian rhythm
that's either a bit longer but shorter
than
24 hours and so you'll you'll kind of
see yourself
um not aligning anymore to the sun
and um it's only when you're sort of
being driven in some way
uh more most directly i think by light
um that
uh that you end up lining up that way
and and you know when when you
change time zones if you travel to the
other side of the world where you're
off by you know eight time zones or
something um so that um that then
you end up getting this jet lag
phenomenon where you have a whole
elaborate sort of uh resynchronization
that has to happen
and so it's kind of an awkward one
because actually it turns out it seems
like every cell in your body has some
knowledge of this kind of whole 24-hour
overall
cycle and so when you are sort of
resetting it maybe you but by an
eight-hour reset or something
um you end up having to slowly over the
course of weeks or even months
um sort of reset the circadian rhythm of
all those cells
and certainly i've i've noticed you know
times when i've been
sort of traveling around the world and
getting jet lag and so on
there are all these elaborate phenomena
that happen where you kind of have a
reflection
12 hours away from where you would
normally go to sleep you start feeling
tired and
you can actually work out the equations
for some of these things and you can
have some understanding of what
the um uh what what the what way what
the way that works is and actually
one can imagine and and some people
actually um
i was some nice work done with our
welcome language technology
to um uh to figure out sort of what is
the optimal way to pace yourself um
if you know you're traveling to a place
that's an eight hour uh
time difference away you know in the
days before you go and in the days after
you arrive
you know what when should you go to
sleep and get up again
so that you minimize the kind of the
effects of this uh
sort of phase resetting of your
circadian rhythm
um anyway that that's a that's a few
thoughts about um
about sleep let's see
um
okay there's a question about
triangles and the significance of
triangles
well you can talk a little bit about
that so
you have a triangle and one feature of a
triangle is if it has
if it's corners sort of a are just
loosely attached they're just sort of um
they're
they can they can they can deform they
can get
um the angles can get larger and smaller
one feature of a triangle is it's rigid
and so in other words once once you have
a triangle with its three side lengths
there's no way you can kind of squidge
it
if you had if you had a quadrilateral a
four-sided thing then
yeah you might have a square but if if
the angles can change you can just
deform it
to being a parallelogram it doesn't have
to stay a square
there's a there's a theorem uh due to a
french mathematician in the 1800s that
is the statement that the triangle is
the only
uh structure that is uh
uh rigid in that sense i think that's
right um
the um uh that has this feature that
you can't um uh that if you just define
the lengths of the sides
um but you don't define the angles the
the lengths of the sides alone will
define its angles and so
if you make a mechanical structure out
of uh a triangle
it it there's no way if if you maintain
the side lengths there's no way that the
thing can kind of squidge over
so so what well if you look at a lot of
metal work on bridges and things like
that you'll see these trusses
and these trusses are all made with a
bunch of triangles and the reason for
that is exactly this phenomenon
if there were squares then then that
square could kind of deform and the
bridge could sort of uh
fall over or whatever but but
because you know steel or something the
bridge is made out of
is is quite it doesn't okay the the
thing to understand is
there are materials like steel that if
you take them you try and you try and
bend them
they do successfully bend but if you try
and squash them
they don't uh well actually they're the
best example of that
okay the the um yeah the the
if that yes that well it's true of a
steel but it's even more true for some
other materials
that you know it if you try and sort of
squash it from the ends
it will be hard to to compress it but if
you just try and uh
try and bend it in the middle it's it's
much easier to bend
and so that's that's a reason why it's a
good idea to make these trusses where
you make these little triangular pieces
because then what's happening is each
one of those triangular pieces
um it can't change its its shape
without changing the lengths of the
sides but the lengths of the sides
as you know have it have a strong
material that can't be compressed there
um and so it pro it's prevented from
from changing the lengths of its sides
so that was a thing that's been known in
engineering for a really long time
that um that if you have these sort of
members these these struts and things
that the way you make a strong structure
is you have to have a bunch of triangles
in it and that's
that's because the triangle is the shape
that doesn't deform
um when if you keep the lengths of the
sides constant
so there are other ways of getting sort
of fairly stable structures
there's a whole family of stable fairly
stable structures and i'm not sure i'm
going to be able to
completely do this justice there's this
uh there was this chap called
buckminster fuller who was a kind of
colorful character
who studied a lot kind of the forms and
shapes of things
and he was very big on this idea that he
called tensegrity
um and the idea there is sort of a
generalization of this what doesn't
deform
when you do certain kinds of operations
and
uh in particular uh he was very big on
the idea of making gd6 domes
which uh so so okay so if you have a um
uh how do you make a a dome
out of um just sort of little struts
what's the best way to make it
well let's say you made a um a thing
that was just a bunch of equilateral
triangles just a grid of equilateral
triangles
that would just lie flat if everything
is triangles
it just lies flat if everything is
hexagons it also lies flat or squares
those are all things where you can just
make sort of tiles that are just pure
squares
pure hexagons pure equilateral triangles
and
you can just lay them as a flat tiling
um those are
those are examples of of cases where
where the tiling is flat but now imagine
that see whether you can do that with
pentagons with regular pentagons
you try and fit those pentagons together
if you fit a bunch of regular pentagons
together
they won't lie flat in fact if you just
start with one regular pentagon you put
other regular pentagons around it
um what you'll make is the net of a of a
shape of a dodecahedron
um and so what will happen is the only
way to have those next hexagons be
these pentagons be be have their sides
right next to each other
is to curl them up into a dodecahedron
into a
into a 12 faced object so
so if you have if you have hexagons you
can make an infinite flat tiling
if you have pentagons you can you can uh
the only thing you can make is this
dodecahedron
which curls up like a kind of discrete
version of a sphere
so the idea that um uh
uh exists in jd6 domes and so on is what
if you mix
hexagons and pentagons so it's mostly
hexagons
but there are a few pentagons in there
so so that means that it doesn't
things can't lie completely flat because
you've got these pentagons
that don't let it be completely flat
they add some curvature to the whole
thing
well there's one sort of famous example
of where that's done which is in soccer
balls
soccer balls have a mixture of uh if you
look at kind of the stitching
on them they have a mixture of hexagons
and pentagons
and they are uh and that's and so if
they were pure pentagons
then they wouldn't be able to be a an
approximation to a sphere
they would just be dodecahedral soccer
balls which might be kind of interesting
to
to operate with but um if you want to
make a soccer ball that's really a ball
but you want to make it out of more or
less
flat pieces you have to mix hexagonal
pieces with pentagonal pieces
and the the fewer pentagons you have in
there
the flatter things will be so if you
want to make a really really big dome
you would have a bunch of hexagons and
not so many pentagons in it
but so this idea of of making jd sick
domes for example
out of a mixture of um of hexagons and
pentagons that's that's sort of an
example
and there's a there's a sense in which
there's stability there's this kind of
tensegrity form of stability
that you get um when there is a sort of
a mixture
of of a force due to gravity for example
together with the um the kind of
stability of having these struts
arranged in a particular way
so that that's um now actually
you know when it comes to judy sick
domes you know
old uh buckminster fuller you know came
up with them and and
started uh building they were used for
they've been used for all kinds of
things
uh famously there's one at disney world
and um that was an early one that
i think like mr fuller did there's one
some in a bunch of different places that
they're commonly used you know if you
see like a
uh some kind of um um radar
uh you know or a satellite tracking
thing they'll typically be a gdc dome
that covers it
just because it's a convenient way to
make sort of a dome-like thing
um and so
judaism domes sort of started getting
used in the 1950s 1960s
by by us humans but they've been used by
other things a very very long time
so so the this sort of idea of making a
sphere out of out of um
out of these sort of uh uh polygonal
pieces
well it's used in in biology quite a bit
it's used in
for example radial area kind of the
things the little tiny
organisms that you find in the ocean
where they have a um
uh a sort of skeleton made of um uh what
is it organo silicates
um that's a uh it's some kind of um it's
something a little bit like
sort of a a piece of a tiny piece of
rock sort of a
crystal that's like a tiny piece of rock
but they tend to form into these kinds
of shapes
same with pollen grains same with some
some kinds of virus coats or
virus coats are often actually
icosahedral for example um rather than
forming into
into these um kind of more approximately
spherical shapes
but so there are a bunch of places where
that um uh
where that sort of idea has been used
before
so anyway the the um uh but the point is
that there's sort of a
an elaborate analysis that you can make
of given these geometrical shapes
what what kind of stability do you get
and what to what extent can you
approximate spheres and
and all kinds of things like this but
triangles are really special because
they have this property
that allows you to kind of make trusses
that are that don't um
uh don't deform in that way um and well
there are all kinds of other sort of
clever ideas about using different
geometries
you know making these kind of honeycomb
things where they're where they deform
in one direction they don't deform in
the other direction all those kinds of
things
also people have made molecules that are
uh the shape of jd6 domes or gd6 spheres
so to speak
mixtures of hexagonally connected um
atoms and pentagonally connected atoms
they're usually called buckyballs and
they're most famously made out of carbon
um and uh you can make these different
sizes
shapes of sizes of of approximately
spherical
kind of cages of of of carbon that
um potentially useful for things that
the more useful form
is this thing called graphene which is
kind of a tube-like version
of the same kind of idea that has all
kinds of interesting properties of being
a very good electrical conductor
like a wire and and potentially very
strong and you can kind of uh
um imagine using them for all kinds of
purposes but i think the
the actual um the spherical cages also
are potentially useful as well
all right let's see um
there's a question here actually quite
related to this from mikhail about our
quasi crystals useful
okay what is a quasi crystal so i was
explaining to you
that if you have a um uh
if you're trying to tile a plane you're
trying to
you know put tiling down in your
bathroom or something
what shapes of tiles can you use well
you can use square tiles
just put the tiles or one down next to
each other you can use hexagonal tiles
you can use triangular tiles
but you cannot use regular pentagons as
tiles
and actually there's a limited set of
shapes you can use there's some other
tilings you can use if you
if you allow a pair of tiles you can use
as a very nice tiling sometimes called
the kepler tiling
there's a mixture of octagons and
squares so you have an octagon octagons
on their own can't
regular octagons regular eight-sided
figures on their own can't be used to
make a tiling
but if you mix them with an octagon and
then uh
four squares around the around some of
the edges of the octagon
then you can make this combined octagons
and squares tiling and you can just
continue the tiling forever
so one question is when you make one of
these tilings does it
is it repetitive you know if you have a
square tiling you just
wrap squares here another row of squares
here another row of squares here
all those rows of squares are identical
so wherever you were on this kind of
tiling floor
it would always look the same it would
always be be identical it would be
in invariant under sort of moving around
it would be unchanged under moving
around on
on the floor so to speak the question is
is that always the way things work
or is there an arrangement of is are
there tiles
that have the property that there is a
way to fill
the infinite you know bathroom floor or
whatever
but um you can't do it periodically you
can't do it so that there's always a
repeating pattern
that just goes the same thing the same
thing the same thing the same thing it's
the same
let's say pair of tiles that you're
using but the detailed arrangement of
that pair of tiles
um can be completely different in
different places
well people didn't know this and back in
the 1940s
there started to be some results that
came from thinking about the theory of
computation
that basically showed that there could
exist
infinite tilings but the infinite
tilings would be very computationally
complicated they would be very
they would be um i mean in essentially
what will be happening is
as a sort of model of computation a
turing machine um and essentially what
will be happening is
the the um the model of computation
involves you just have this
this tape this one-dimensional tape and
essentially the turing machine would be
kind of
making one row of the tile tiling the
next row the next row the next row
and the question of whether there was an
infinite tiling with the question of
whether the turing machine would never
halt
in its um in in just generating
successive rows of the tiling
and that turns out to be a
computationally difficult problem and
that kind of shows
that there exists tilings which are
messy and complicated whether
is a tiling as possible but it's messy
and complicated
so so then various things were
discovered and and eventually um
uh roger penrose who's somebody i've
known for a long time
uh who also is famous because um uh
he's mathematical physicist who won this
year's um
nobel prize in physics for his work on
on black holes and
and the study of the geometry of space
time but um when he was
much younger um he's very much into sort
of mathematical puzzles and so on
and he discovered invented i'm not sure
how you say it
these things that are usually called
penrose tiles which are a pair of tiles
that have the property that there is a
way to make them fill up the whole plane
but there's no way to do that
periodically and essentially the way
they work is
well there's a kite shaped tile and
there's a dart shaped tile
and essentially what happens is
you can lay down a particular pattern of
these sort of kites and darts
and then you can imagine taking that
pattern a kind of uh
sort of taking a sub-piece of it
and you end up with this kind of nested
structure of sort of patterns and
sub-patterns and so on
and that's that in that nested pattern
it's possible to have the kites and
darts fill up the plane
infinitely but only in but it's not
possible to do that
having them be periodic be just a
repeating pattern
there's there's other ways to make them
fill the plane other than this nested
pattern
but the nested pattern proves that it is
possible for them to fill the whole
plane
so actually i've been long curious
whether there is a simpler version of
that so it's known that there's no
single tile in one dimension in two
dimensions at least just on a plane
there's no single tile that lets you uh
forces non-periodicity
but allows tiling it's not known in
three dimensions it's possible there
could be a three-dimensional shape
that could fill space where you could
you could arrange it all together
but um it doesn't uh it doesn't do that
periodically at least i believe that's
um that that's not knowing whether
that's possible
so in even in two dimensions
um there's sort of the question of of
okay so
there's something where there's no
periodic tiling that's possible but
there is this nested tiling that penrose
tiles allow
can one find a simple tile set of tiles
that will allow um not just um
uh that will force you to have some much
more complicated pattern where the only
way to tile the plane
is something much more complicated so
that uh in a sense what you if you can
find that
then insofar as actual atoms and let's
say you can get at something which is
molecules that are those shapes
then if you say well i'm going to let
i'm going to i'm going to have this
liquid
where all these molecules just running
around randomly and i'm going to cool it
down and it's going to become a crystal
where all those molecules are lined up
and the only way they can line up
is in this very complicated arrangement
then this is a way to kind of
create an object with a very complicated
arrangement
at the atomic scale we don't usually
have that in a crystal in a standard
crystal
the atoms are all arranged in a in this
very periodic way
unless there's a defect in the crystal
or unless there are different um
uh parts of the crystal a twin twin
crystal or something like that
um you don't um the different domains of
the crystal
within a single part of the crystal all
the atoms are precisely lined up in
let's say a hexagonal arrangement a
cubic arrangement
uh they're different there there are um
17
standard arrangements of of um uh in
three dimensions
for possible ways that that crystals can
be can be arranged
but um it's basically uh most of the
time the atoms that we know
it's kind like it's one of those
standard periodic arrangements and
nothing else so something
was discovered in the 1980s is that
actually
there are ways of making
uh quasi crystals where the atoms can
arrange themselves but they can't
arrange themselves periodically
and in particular they can arrange
themselves in these nested patterns a
bit like pinhole styles
actually strangely enough the the
three-dimensional logo
of uh of wolfen alpha and of our company
is this
rhombic hexacontahedron and that object
actually is one of the
sort of uh elements that can be used to
build up a three-dimensional
uh quasi-periodic tiling um so a
quasi-quasi crystal okay so why are
these quasi-crystals
relevant or interesting um i think
the um there are a variety of of strange
features that they have
particularly having to do with the
extent to which
that the lack of periodicity has effects
on the way that periodic things like
light waves and so on which are periodic
will go through the crystal
i suspect that there are things that one
can do that will be really spectacular
if you could kind of more design in
detail the precise
kind of form of that some of that sort
of uh
semi-random pattern random but
repeatable pattern
there probably a lot of things one could
do uh things like um oh
so-called physically unique functions
which are a way of kind of uh
having a password that's burnt into
hardware there's some probably things
some things along those lines
they're probably a bunch of other things
that could be done we don't know how to
make
these kind of not really quasi crystals
but non-crystals so to speak
where the atoms are always arranged the
same in the same kind of a way
but never arranged periodically so i i
maybe i may be forgetting some um
some amazing uses of quasi crystals but
that's some
uh that that's that's at least the
beginning and talking a little bit about
what quasi crystals are
let's see maybe one more um
uh one more question here um
okay there's a question from pratik um
[Music]
what does it mean to map a brain why is
there a race to map the brain correctly
well our brain has about 100 billion
neurons in it
and it is the connections between those
neurons that seem to be the key
to sort of how our brains work um
the our brains are pretty complicated
and none of us
have the same way in which those those
individual neurons are connected
together
if you go to much lower organisms um you
will find
uh that with much tinier brains you will
find that sometimes
their brains are always hooked up in the
same way so the most famous example of
that
is this tiny little nematode worm the c
elegans
which has about 2 000 um
uh cells altogether in it
um each nematode is about 2 000 cells
and they're always arranged the same way
well actually the male organism is
arranged one way the female organism
another way
but the cells are basically arranged the
same in all of these
in every one of these organisms and when
the organism grows
the the you know the cells divide and
they always divide in the same way
to make the same shape and the brain of
that organism i think it's what is it
500 or so
uh neurons something like that i forget
um
the the one feature that the the c
elegans has
is its brain is always arranged the same
way the neurons are always arranged in
exactly the same
uh configuration and um you can you can
kind of trace
oh if you poke you know one piece of the
of the of the critter
then that will excite this neuron which
excites this neuron which will
eventually make the
the foot of the thing move and that's
kind of the full story of how its brain
works
you can trace every every sort of
connection in its brain and you can kind
of see the wiring diagram
that says the the electric circuit and
effect that determines
the the structure of its brain well we
can't expect to do
that for us for us because our brains
don't grow that way we don't all grow
identical brains perhaps that's a good
thing otherwise
we might all behave in absolutely
identical ways and and the world would
probably be a
a less interesting place and a place
less likely to
to see sort of innovation and change and
and the kinds of things that probably
are good for biological evolution
but um the thing that um that we can do
is even though the individual neurons in
our brains are not
uh hooked up in in a in a repeatable way
the areas of our brains are are quite
repeatable
so we'll have you know the visual cortex
in the back of our head the
the the um uh i don't know
my brain parts the sort of frontal lobes
in the front
the motor strip on the top you know all
sorts of other features of the brain
will be arranged in very definite places
now
if you look at an individual brain and
i'm happy to say i've never done that in
in in person so to speak but um if you
uh the brains are they have all this
with humans they have all this sort of
corrugation they're very
they're kind of like a flat surface but
they've all been been been scrunched up
like a like a crumpled piece of paper
and and the details of how that sort of
crumpling and folding works
are very different between different
brains they're even more different than
the fingerprints
which are also sort of a folding related
phenomenon
um so different brains kind of very very
have a very different detailed um
detailed structure like that but still
there are features that are
very similar and um there's sort of a
question
of to what extent can we deduce kind of
global
uh global sort of architecture for the
brain um
and then how do we understand the
connections between different parts of
the brain
different different parts that seem to
be critical to you know
our perception of consciousness critical
to our ability to
um you know assess risk typical of our
ability to process language all these
kinds of things
it's known that um there are
the the particular features of the brain
like that the place that's most critical
for
processing language and so on isn't
always in quite the same place in
different people
um and uh for example people who do
neurosurgery
and who are you know trying to fix
problems inside brains
um always need to kind of poke around
and try and figure out things like
where is the language center because you
really want to avoid that but the things
around it
one doesn't necessarily know what they
do and they may be the things that are
less critical
to to sort of one's everyday uh uh
operation
um and uh you know one thing that's just
a kind of a a weird trivia point
is that that you know the brain and
human brains have has two sides left and
right hemispheres
and they do somewhat different things
and there's always a question if you're
left-handed
as i am um you know ten percent of the
of humans are left-handed
uh i happen to be one of that ten
percent um one's brain is arranged
uh the arrangement is not necessarily
the same as a right-handed um
as a right-handed person and so for
example when there are studies that are
done of kind of brain activity where
people are
using functional mri imaging to for
example figure out which
which areas of the brain are being used
when
you think about uh elephants or
something
um it there is some overall difference
of organization
that seems to exist often for
left-handed people compared to
right-handed people
and so when people do these studies they
usually say oh we're recruiting you know
i don't know students of this type who
have this and this and this
no left-handers so one one of my kids
has always been disappointed that
she's always excluded from these these
kinds of stuff i think she told me she
recently found a study
uh where where they're like yes we'll
have left-handed people but i think it
may have been a study
to do with something to do with
left-handedness so so that may not be uh
be a thing that really counts but anyway
the the thing that um
uh that's of interest is you know to
what extent can we understand the
architecture of the brain
to what extent can we map out how that
works it's not clear
that i mean perhaps there will be one
day sort of a
standard model of a human brain just as
there's a standard human genome
that uh you know is the six billion base
pairs of the human genome
part of it came from one of the people
uh who who uh
figured out how to sequence the human
genome he sort of contributed
his genome to be part of the standard so
to speak
obviously actual each actual human has a
somewhat different genome unless they're
identical twins
um and uh the um
uh but you have to you know you can pick
sort of a standard genome
and then you can say how do people
differ from that standard genome one can
imagine a time when there'll be sort of
a standard brain
where it's like this is the connections
of the brain in some some particular way
well there's some sort of questions
about could you actually map a brain
could if you took a human brain
um could you could you successfully map
it well
it's a lot easier if the brain is not
alive anymore if the brain is alive it's
pretty challenging to see how you would
map it the best idea that people have is
this notion of optogenetics
where basically what you're doing is
you're kind of in training
uh uh into into sort of the the um
the proteins that are produced um by the
operation of
of the brain you're introducing ones
that produce uh produce light like a
jellyfish can produce light
uh using actually the same same kind of
uh technology so to speak
um you're introducing those in such a
way that you can actually have within a
brain you might be able to sort of
measure
um you might be able to sort of detect
this this um
uh you know flashes of light that are
produced and things i suppose you could
also detect
you know you can to some extent measure
the electrical signals associated with
individual
uh individual uh neurons in the brain
i mean the brain is complicated partly
because these neurons tend to be long
and filamentous
and each neuron might connect to a
thousand other neurons and it's a big
it's a big mass of of sort of neuron
wires
going all over the place it's hard to
disentangle but um you know you could
imagine
you take a brain you kind of um
completely freeze it
you kind of have it you put in some some
chemical that will
just like like take um you know there
are chemicals where
which will basically just put sort of
handcuffs on every protein
and and prevent it anything from moving
around you could say well then let's go
take that
and that's kind of just analyze you know
slice by slice let's go through
and let's figure out exactly what was
connected to what and exactly how many
little
little um channels are there inside the
synapses that connect to
one neuron to another and just sort of
measure off exactly how our brain is
working
and then you could imagine doing that
and you can imagine then saying okay
if we know all the features of the brain
that are important and we've kind of
measured them off
let's restart this brain in a digital
form in a computer
and let's then just uh you know then
we'll have something which is kind of
like
like a human brain and that would be a
neat thing to be able to do
we're not quite there yet in terms of
computer power but we're not super far
away
from being able to do that um it's also
not clear that you need to get
to get human-like performance on things
you certainly don't necessarily need the
precise copy of an individual human
brain
if you had that precise copy presumably
you would have something that would be
able to
respond in the same way that actual
human brains respond
i mean i don't know and nobody really
knows to what extent you really need to
go through and work out
every single synapse and every single
thing about the brain
to make a thing that can imitate the
operation of a brain i mean i've
sometimes wondered you know i've
collected uh several million emails and
things and i've
collected a lot of detailed information
about me and what i do and things like
this
and you know these live streams are yet
more data
and it's like at some point you know
could you use all that data to basically
make a bot
of me that just is a you know that
starts from sort of a
um an un untrained neural network of
some kind
and then just feed it all of the stuff
about well this is what
this is what i do about um for this or
that thing
just neural net just imitate that and
and can you sort of knit that together
and expect to get something which is
sort of
a bot of me but but anyway so the the
this um
this question of uh you know can you map
the brain at this microscopic level
can you map the brain as a sort of
larger architectural level
um can you get an understanding a better
understanding of how our brains are
organized and
and you know there's a sort of a
question of to what extent
when we try and make ai systems
artificial intelligence systems and so
on
to what extent should we be imitating
the way brains work and to what extent
should we just taking what's the overall
thing you're trying to make it do
and worry about that i mean it's it's
like asking if you're trying to make an
airplane
to what extent does it need feathered
wings and so on like a bird
well the answer is you know there aren't
too many feathered wing airplanes that
have ever worked
um the the the the details of you know
making an airplane out of aluminum
and having you know jet engines and
things like that very different from
making a bird out of out of bone
and uh and feathers and so on and having
it work that way so
so it's not completely clear that one
wants to have um you know to what extent
copying the the details you know what
level of detail of copying the human
brain
is useful um but it's certainly
interesting to know more about how
brains work um
and although we may very well find that
quite a lot of over the way the brain
works
is like oh you don't need that that's
you know it's like saying you know do
the wings of the airplane need to flap
no they don't you know do you need
feathers on the wings no you don't
if your purpose is to make a thing that
uh
you know flies around and can take
people and cargo and things like that
then it's perfectly adequate to have
this aluminum thing with fixed wings
if your purpose was exactly to reproduce
what you know
what an owl does or something then yes
you probably need an
owl and if you if you get to enough
level of detail you're probably
exactly an owl so the question is when
we're reproducing sort of brain-like
things
what level of detail do we want to
reproduce these things at um
and that that sort of determines um how
we should best think about it
all right well unfortunately i have to
uh
wrap this up now but um i see a
quite a number of interesting questions
which i would have loved to
to tackle and um perhaps we can leave
them until next time
so thanks very much and uh bye for now